die ukraine die kämpfen wirklich
erbittert um jeden meter land jeden mit
meter ihrer heimat und herr schneider
sie waren hauptmann beim legendären ksk
sie sind ausgebildet für häuserkampf
hinterhalt also genau das was wir hier
gleich hinter uns sehen werden und werde
nicht auf play drücken und wir uns
gemeinsam die arbeit von so einem panzer
vernichtungs trupp angucken sagen sie
einmal wie wichtig ist moral ist mut in
so einer situation wenn man als soldat
gegen einen russischen panzer kämpft
es ist entscheidend
motivation ist ein wesentlicher faktor
in bezug auf die kampfkraft eine ahnung
das heißt ich kann ganz viele panzer
haben ich kann ganz viel ausrüstung
haben wenn die soldaten die diese
ausrüstung nicht bedienen können oder
wollen spricht motiviert sind dann nützt
mir die beste armee der welt nichts dann
nützt mir die die beste ausrüstung wie
beurteilen sie das taktische vorgehen
wir haben beide im vorfeld ja über
dieses video hier gesprochen wie sehen
sie die die arbeit der ukrainischen
soldaten wie gut sind hier ausgebildet
wir sehen hier
ich denke mal ich kann es nicht
verifizieren aber ich denke mal wir sind
hier in jedem fall spezialisierte
infanterie vielleicht sogar
spezialkräfte wir sehen gute ausrüstung
wir sind ballistische gefechte wir sehen
ein schnellfeuergewehr mit einem
sogenannten endpoint also ein lichtpunkt
bisher und auf der anderen seite sehen
wir eine relativ alte panzerabwehrwaffe
nämlich die rpg der der russen oder
russischer bauart
also von daher ausrüstungs technisch auf
jeden fall auf auf der höhe und diese
rpg tut ihren zweck werden im bereich in
diesem bereich zwischen 80 und 200 meter
vor allem wenn es um stehen der tiere
geht und wir sehen dass das taktische
vorgehen sehr sehr gut war der rheiner
bis ihnen einlass sicherer er also den
panzer festsitzen entsprechend sichert
und das macht alles einen sehr guten
einen sehr professionellen
ich möchte noch ein anderes russischen
sieht das etwas anders aus ja ich möchte
ihnen noch ein anderes video zeigen dass
hier das ist ein dach und auf dem dach
da sind ukrainische soldaten in stellung
gegangen und der hier der hat auch eine
panzer ab der waffe da wenn wir gleich
sehen wie eine rakete in diese richtung
fliegt und vielleicht können sie uns da
noch mal mit reinnehmen in die situation
wer macht hier was von den soldaten und
ja wie beurteilen sie dieses taktische
vorgehen
also auch hier ein zehntes taktisches
vorgehen die soldaten befinden sich auf
einer in einer erhöhten feuer position
der soldat der diese panzerabwehrwaffe
abschießt wird von infanterie
gesichert diese schauen dass aus dem
nahbereich eben nicht das feuer durch
infanteristen erwidert wird und ja wir
sehen hier eine andere waffe gesehen
kein rpg ich glaube wert ist eine eine
waffe schwedischer bauart die er auf
etwas längere distanzen wirkt und die
auch einen eigenen feuer leitrechner
also eine etwas modernere
version dessen was wir vorher gesehen
haben macht es für den staat einfacher
und da ist vor allem dann in einem vip
bereich von 300 bis 600 meter sehr
effektiv darf ich sie einmal fragen das
ist alles dieses ich denn das mal so
taktische soldaten sprech was man immer
wieder hört aber wenn man da oben auf
dem dach sitzt wenn man über sich keine
deckung hat wenn man in 2 300 meter
entfernung russische panzer rollen sieht
hat man da angst hat man da denkt man da
an die eigene familie oder ist das in
dem moment alles ausgeschaltet und es
geht nur um eine rakete meine mission
und diesen russischen panzer
also ich denke mal seit mix und so wie
ich diese soldaten jetzt hier sehe und
einschätze machen die das nicht das
erste mal also es nicht das bestimmt
nicht der erste panzer den die
abschließen und ein soldat gewöhnt sich
natürlich an das umfeld in dem er agiert
also endlich mal ein mix aus aus angst
achtsamkeit auf der einen seite und auf
der anderen seite der auftrag und die
mission nämlich das land zu verteidigen
die die das eigene land zu verteidigen
und am ende des tages sehen wir hier
schon wirklich ein ort zum häuserkampf
und das wird sich eventuell auch noch
weiter verstärken wenn es dann nachts
ihren verein geht und er verteidiger hat
es im orts- und häuserkampf einfach
leichter um erfolge zu erzielen sie
sprechen den orts- und häuserkampf an
lassen sie uns gemeinsam auf die
aktuelle situation in kiew schauen wir
haben mal probiert basierend auf den
aktuellen gefechts karten die uns
vorliegen ein diagramm darzustellen wo
die russischen truppen gerade stehen wo
der vormarsch auf kiel stattfindet und
wo eben ja die soldaten die ukrainischen
soldaten probieren die stellung zu
halten wir sehen eben einmal den
vormarsch aus west wir sehen hier ein
vormarsch aus ost über dem wir auch seit
tagen sprechen mittlerweile hier an der
ostfront ukrainische soldaten auch
umstellt und eingekesselt und eben immer
wieder wir sprechen darüber die autobahn
und die bahnstrecke die hier in den
westen führt und wo eben mittlerweile
auch ja darum gekämpft wird wenn sie auf
dieses komplexe lagebild schauen als
militär welche front würde ihn da am
meisten sorgen bereiten wo muss man
genau hinschauen das am ende hier
vielleicht nicht umgesetzt werden kann
ja das thema der umstellung ist ist
natürlich ein thema als sti um wirklich
diese diesen uralt ansatz der belagerung
zu fahren spricht dass das aushungern
das ausbluten am ende des tages einer
stadt wie wir es aus anderen kriegen
konnten im zweiten weltkrieg war das
auch eine eine häufig angewandte taktik
und strategie
das ist das eine das andere ist ich
fühle mich ein bisschen fraglich und
nicht nur für mich sondern für viele
andere militärexperten oder im militär
interessierte was will putin erreichen
und will er seine truppen wirklich nach
tierfreien schicken in diesen
verlustreiche nordhäuser kampf und
zwischen kämpfen und hat inzwischen
nehmen und halten ist das militärisch
und eben auch noch mal ein himmelweiter
unterschied die frage ist wie soll
jemals eine großstadt wikis oder auch
eine ausstellung statt mit charkiw
gehalten werden ich brauche dafür sehr
viel truppe ich brauche dafür sehr viel
infanterie und wie wir sehen hatte hat
putin das nicht und er hat über
schleppte logistik wege wir sehen sie
immer wieder panzer die verlassen wurden
die nicht abgeschlossen wurden die
einfach kein diesel matten und das sind
die da sind die probleme die ihm die
russische seite zu seite schneider
vielen vielen dank für ihre
expertise